a warning her report includes images of
the bodies of some victims killed when
the russians took over
ukrainian forces are on a roll
russia's front line quite literally
crumbling
the control of land they fought to
capture now gone in ukraine's lightning
advance
access to this area is still heavily
restricted but the police have agreed to
take us to a village that until three
days ago was under russian control
the residents of zales nichna seemed
quite dazed by what's happened
vasil lived through the second world war
and then six months of terror under the
russians
across the street the police are finally
able to investigate russia's suspected
war crimes
they've come to retrieve the bodies of
two men
both had been shot dead in this
semi-detached house where one of the
victims lived
his next-door neighbor found the men and
had to bury them in the garden
maria shows us her end of the property
and where it had been hit by shrapnel
during the occupation oh well that must
have been really scary for you
cheers
there's been no power in this village
for months
with winter coming she's scared of the
cold
and the possibility of the russians
returning
there have been a lot of dark times
a local industrial site is also a crime
scene
police climb up to retrieve the body of
a security guard shot dead in late
february as the russians advanced
left to rot
now free residents describe russia's
chaotic
[Music]
but there's also much trauma
russian soldiers shot this man's brother
dead he doesn't know why
[Applause]
his brother laid to rest here
awaiting justice
debra haynes sky news in harkev region